[Music]
welcome to the program americans are
being urged to stay clear of
afghanistan's main airport because of a
credible threat president joe biden has
already warned another attack on kabul
airport is highly likely within 36 hours
and he's vowed further strikes against
isil following thursday's suicide
bombing which killed at least 175 people
gabriel alisonde reports now from
washington dc
friday's drone strike that killed two
isil k members and wounded another was
the first retaliatory strike against the
group but according to president joe
biden it won't be the last it's unclear
if those killed had a direct role in
thursday's airport attack that killed
over 150 afghans and over a dozen u.s
military personnel
the pentagon won't release the names of
the isil k members they killed only
saying they were planning future attacks
i am not going to talk about
specific capabilities isis may have lost
in this strike they lost a planner and
they lost a facilitator and they've got
one wounded
and the fact that two of these
individuals are no long longer walking
on the face of the earth that's a good
thing it's a good thing for the people
of afghanistan it's a good thing for our
troops and our forces at that airfield
and i think i'm just going to leave it
there
the u.s and the taliban are coordinating
on airport security that cooperation did
not extend to the drone strike
a taliban spokesperson told reuters news
agency they should have been informed
before the airstrike took place
in a statement saturday afternoon biden
said the chance of another terrorist
attack in the next 24 to 36 hours is
very high it's believed around 4 000 u.s
troops are still at the airport in kabul
and commanders say despite the risks the
mission continues until the august 31st
deadline biden has put in place
threats to our forces and to this
operation remain real and significant
i'm sure you can appreciate that and now
as the military mission trend begins to
end in kabul thousands of service
members are working across the globe and
within the united states to complete
this incredibly important mission caught
in the middle innocent afghan civilians
at an airport near washington on
saturday afghan evacuees continued to
arrive in america after an arduous
journey
well i would say
last six or seven days
have been the toughest days of my life
honestly i don't want to lie or i don't
want to exaggerate but
it is how it is
things are really bad all around the
airport all the entrances
and
you kind of feel lucky if you can get
just through those gates
over the weekend america was learning
more of the u.s service members killed
in the suicide attack max soviet a navy
medic was one of them he was only two
years old when the u.s invaded
afghanistan in 2001
friends and family back in his hometown
of ohio are grieving his death
he was just a really
good kid and
you know that everybody liked everybody
loves the family
just very
well respected
the u.s military pullout from
afghanistan was measured in months and
then weeks and now it's down to days and
it could be the most unpredictable and
dangerous phase of all
with president biden
simultaneously warning americans that
there could be more attacks against u.s
troops in kabul
while also more strikes against those
the u.s says is responsible
gabriel lozando al jazeera washington
meanwhile the taliban says kabul airport
will be under its control very soon as
it bolsters security following
thursday's attack
the sound of gunfire rang out near the
international airport earlier witnesses
say the taliban was firing to disperse
people trying to get on evacuation
flights crowds outside the airport have
reportedly thinned after an increase in
taliban checkpoints nearby the group is
now escorting a limited number of
afghans inside rob mcbride has more now
from the afghan capital
at kabul international airport a real
sense that we're now getting into the
end game of this very long and often
chaotic and traumatic evacuation process
the surest sign of that has come with
the taliban now taking over some of the
guarding duties from the u.s military as
they reduce their perimeter in
preparation for their final departure
for the final american boots to be off
the ground we have seen taliban fighters
take over guard post on the perimeter
and actually inside the airport itself
the imminent end of this evacuation
though has not stopped still crowds of
people around the perimeter trying to
get on some of the last flights you do
get a feeling that a lot of people will
have given up hope by now and i'm not
going back to the airport especially
with warnings of possibly more attacks
for others though the imminent ending of
this whole process has probably made it
added to the desperation of trying to
get on one of the last remaining flights
but there are relatively few left now as
we see fewer flights arriving and taking
off meanwhile in the city of kabul
itself there is a mixed picture here as
the
city goes back to work after what for
many has been the
weekend here in afghanistan businesses
have largely reopened some ministries
have reopened as they did last week but
other ministries have remained closed
and crucially for many people here again
the banks are closed the banking sector
here has been a real problem ever since
the fall of the government and the
takeover by the taliban they some
financial services opened briefly uh
just over a week ago you could the cash
machines opened but with very tight
limits on the amount of money people
could take out
finally they opened a few days ago but
now they were meant to reopen saturday
but they have remained closed so people
have not been able to get access to
their funds access to salaries in some
cases people are complaining they
haven't been paid for months it has led
to angry scenes outside many banks
protests and it is a bad
bad sign for the country and this new
taliban government moving forward
meanwhile hundreds of afghans have
protested outside banks in kabul while
others formed long lines at cash
machines
government employees were among those
marching demanding their salaries they
say they have not been paid for several
months and cash withdrawals at atms have
been limited to about 200 every 24 hours
it's almost 10 days that i've been
waiting here to get my salary i am an
employee of the government we have a
patient at home we have our problems we
cannot take our salaries out a few days
ago the banks reopened but are closed
again give us our salaries so that we
can be able to solve our problems
the last british military flight has
left kabul taking the uk's remaining
diplomats and troops out of afghanistan
it marks the end of nearly 20 years of
british military presence the final
flight carrying afghan civilians left
earlier on saturday but hundreds of
people entitled to resettlement in the
uk have been left behind
barbara reports
her name is hava even english and she's
just entered a world full of hope and
uncertainty
her afghan parents were evacuated from
kabul to dubai where they caught a
turkish airlines flight to the uk helped
by the cabin crew her mom soman had to
give birth on board
as havor arrived the british military
confirmed it was ending its flights
carrying civilians france has done the
same
shakiba an afghan actress living in
france managed to get her mother and
brother out of afghanistan at the last
minute as in so many cases it involved
days of frantic phone calls to people on
the ground at the airport
i've rediscovered the smell of my mother
and it's something that i'd forgotten
my mother's tears reminded me of the
tears she shed when i left afghanistan
it was really moving
a lot of emotions today
shabir an afghan journalist filmed
himself as he and nine close relatives
waited to get onto one of the final
evacuation flights he's now in spain
spending night and day in the airport
and the gate
was one of the worst experiences i have
ever had i never
was forced to spend the night
with my family
in an open place like that with
thousands of people
not in the worst
days of afghanistan
shabir and his family are now seeking
asylum but the british government admits
up to 1100 afghans eligible to be
resettled in the uk mainly because they
worked with british troops are being
left behind the head of the uk armed
forces says it's heartbreaking
personally i've probably had
over 100 messages from different afghans
who i know in my long association with
the country and many of those
friends of mine won't make it out
at this small organization near london
they're scrambling to help people still
trying to get out of afghanistan their
founder says it's clear there are many
still in danger
the british government should
act immediately in order to save the
life of other thousands of other people
who
been working
for the past 20 years supporting the
nato mission
as these afghan civilians arrived in
rome a nato representative said his team
had done everything they could
unsatisfied because we have left a few
behind which we are not abandoning
but
which we will strive our best to take
back home
as the sun sets on the military
evacuations the question now is how many
more people who fear for their lives
will be able to leave afghanistan and
how
nadeem baba al
jazeera france and italy have joined a
number of european countries that have
now completed their evacuation missions
but french president emmanuel macron
says he's in preliminary talks with the
taliban with the hope of facilitating
further evacuation flights while
allowing humanitarian operations to
continue with the help of qatar
we are currently having discussions
which are very fragile and preliminary
that is why i am being very careful in
my answer but yes discussions have begun
with the taliban on the issues of
humanitarian operations and the ability
to protect and repatriate afghans who
are at risk
and yes we are working alongside with
qatar to allow these operations to
proceed
canadians have been rallying across the
country to raise awareness about the
humanitarian crisis in afghanistan in
toronto crowds called on the government
to do more for those who've been left
behind in afghanistan the demonstrations
come days after canada announced it
would end its evacuation mission
we want to make sure that the afghan
situation is not forgotten and at the
same time that there is accountability
we need the canadian government all
three parties to ensure that enough
sufficient aid is going to our afghan
people and our allies who have helped
out we want them to take action we want
them to extend the deadline august 31st
is not acceptable and not only that they
decided to end the
evacuation five days earlier which was
just on thursday that's unacceptable our
families are still stuck